Speaker 1: Right wingers have gotten us
banned from being able to post the tik tok.
I don't even know where to start, but this is
quite frankly, completely demoralizing. We have
been posting on the platform Tik Tok for a while
now. We have built up more than 200,000 followers
on TikTok. The fastest growth of any platform on
which we have ever published content has been.
Tik Tok The growth has been incredible. It has
become a huge part of our content distribution.
Tik Tok Content moderation system is a disaster.
It's heavily automated and it appears as though
when human reviewers are involved they either
don't understand the content or are hypocrites.
I don't know. And because we have had dozens of
videos flagged by right wingers wrongly flagged
as violating all sorts of different disinformation
policies, although most of those we have appealed
successfully. Enough of them we have not that now
we are banned from posting to Tik Tok for some
period of time. Take a look at this. When we enter
Tik Tok, we now see your account is in view only
mode. That means can't post can't comment due to
multiple violations of our community guidelines.
Your account is restricted to view only mode. The
next violation could result in being permanently
banned. This is a major hit to what we are doing
and the messages we are trying to get out. Look
at some of these examples of our violations.
Senator Mike Braun says he would be okay leaving
the legality of interracial marriage to states.
That was from March. We posted that and said
how horrible it was that Mike Braun said that.
Mike Braun really said that we got a violation
because the content was found to be intended
to deceive or mislead. That's insane. We were
debunking what Mike Braun genuinely said.
Next example, I interviewed Bobby Patton,
a Republican for U.S. Senate. He made false claims
about the 2020 election. I debunked those claims.
And we got a violation for that. Trump Is Confused
by Election Fraud Documentary. This was an
interview that Luke Beasley did with someone
who told lies about the 2020 election. Luke
Beesley confronted those lies. Lies. We called out
those lies and it was found to violate community
guidelines. And we also have one which is under
appeal wherein Donald Trump called Joe Biden
the enemy of the state. That's literally what
Trump said. We talked about how corrosive and
destructive that is. We received a community
guideline strike. These are right wingers,
mass reporting us. So what can we do? I don't know
if you work at Tech. If you know anyone who works
at TikTok, please get us in touch. Email info at
David Pakman dot com. This is a really important
platform on which we are reaching young people who
vote. This is a huge part of our outreach and the
MAGA people by mass reporting us have gotten it
taken away. And part listen. They do this on every
platform. They do this on YouTube. YouTube has
figured out how not to allow these people just
simply because they don't like my opinion to shut
down my channel. Tik Tok is not figured it out.
You know anyone at Tik Tok? Please get in touch.
Put us in touch. We need help. In addition,
get yourselves a membership on our website.
We all all of these platforms take up time
and resources. And every time that something like
this happens, we then have to request additional
help and additional resources and additional time.
The best thing we can do in order to not rely on
any individual platform is to continue growing
the direct support from our viewers. So I would
love it if you signed up at join pacman dot com
coupon code. Big voting 22 gets you a discount